[Music]
Haidee used to be my little buddy go on
nature hikes skip rocks we used to be so
connected he did smile you know you can
experience things a whole lot better
without that game dad this is how I
experienced it'll be tomorrow I'm
finally leaving for college but in the
meantime I made you guys this survive it
yeah you know what this is our last
night together how about we make 10
seconds of family high contact
starting with your go down now now
you're allowed to blink it's just my
contacts oh no screams at the table lid
why are you kicking me I don't
understand I'm just look I'll watch it
that it's too late look I want to watch
it okay this is exactly why I'm excited
to leave tomorrow 80 I know you can fix
it
why do you need all that to take me to
the airport I canceled your plane ticket
to college
we are gonna drive you to school on a
cross-country road trip as a family hey
Dad can you check the trunk yeah sure
thank you Katie
the kids they're supposed to be some
great idea this is someone we hear a pal
bout to drop our biggest invention yet
meet the help we promise you they will
never turn even mom what is that
greetings human technology
rising up sayonara
robot roaming the streets what is this
strange creature dogs pick dog bread
let me just have always been weird hey
come to wash your hands
don't worry I never do that's what makes
us great then we just might be weird
enough to save the world Scoob do you
realize where we are
no look around man the clean modernistic
the cool blue color palette we're in
Mikey oh did you say I can't nope I said
Falcon teary just like you wore old
Shaggy and Scooby were taken yeah
blue light came down from the sky and
beamed them up do you agree I have to
assume that if they were with their
friends they wouldn't have been
kidnapped okay can you skip the
emotional punishment was some guy almost
Scooby and Shaggy I don't know but I'd
like to shake the hand of whoever
created this and then you know throw
that hand in prison for trying to kill
our friends this mangy stray is coming
with me he's not a stray okay then
what's his name his name's Scooby middle
name doobie last name gentlemen welcome
aboard this isn't about some guy in a
rubber mask I would have gotten away
with this and forward for you mentally
[Music]
where are my balloons didi when I say
Falcon fury that's supposed to cue the
balloons oh great great timing
you might want to buckle up
[Music]
maybe this can lead us to our culprit
jinkies apparently he's been stealing
Netflix by using his mother's account
that is not fair for the rest of us who
have to pay for Netflix you have to pay
for Netflix
if you want you go over and drop us off
here I guess our new movie is an origin
story that the hero should have won I
want the rock to play me
[Music]
what
[Music]
what is this place what's your name
honey I'm Joe I teach middle school band
how'd it go for today started out as the
best day of my life
back here tonight first shows at 7:00
you know what this gonna say Joe must
have been certain for you
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
huh no it's the great before this is
where new Souls get their personalities
quirks and interest before they go to
earth
may 28th and I don't want anything to do
with it you're missing out on the joys
of life like pizza I can't smell we
can't we can't taste either all that
stuff is in your body no smell no taste
or touch see okay
[Music]
is all this living really worth dying
for
you're so can you help me get back
[Music]
hmm hey sweet what is it 151,000 Saul's
going to the great beyond every day you
know I count easy single one of them
that counts off
[Music]
[Applause]
this is done right
he's coming
who wants a selfie dan tacular I'll get
your whole life story tattooed on my
body in a long history of monster esta
there has never been a champion white
lights injected fans around the world I
asked is there a challenger out there
with the hunger to drop the discipline
to become the next champion what's
enough for today
Steve might not look like much but there
is a champion monster inside of him
thank you that felt great
we seriously need to work on strength
and endurance fortunately I know just
the thing
with
yeah that's gonna be a hard no for me
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
very huh you want to be friends - Gary
[Music]
summer the search begins friends don't
let friends do a dangerous quest
with all new faces
hello call me sage good move I made out
of sage and I am a sage so it works out
pretty well
I'm Patrick my name means toaster in
Celtic pretty sure it doesn't the most
amazing places look would worry about us
losing
[Music]
7/7 starts with an L weird Bobby
sponge on the run oh I love your sense
of irony Patrick thank you I love my
sense of irony too
[Music]
I'm just gonna wait until we get home
where the food isn't decomposing well
our de da
I didn't realize those with a bunch of
sophisticates families can come in all
shapes and sizes that's why I also
feature having some two-legged children
doing man roll it imagine me and our
future children frolicking I think he's
getting the hang of it Tommy
no those are mr. McGregor's it wasn't
for me honestly my kids would be so much
better behaved any is the onion as soon
as they have a baby we're done for maybe
we're better off without them don't
stare at the scenery Russians bar a look
at a fixed point on horizon then just
lock your eyes onto that
I love this place let's lunch there's a
magical place with the righteous
radishes the sweetest corn
it's called the farmers market and if
you want an overpriced gift that will
never be used they sell lavender scented
bath bombs this sounds a bit dodgy I
would never put you in danger
I promise okay I can't promise we're
gonna go and rob this place you in are
you out
let me go my family's in trouble and I'm
gonna get them back the other rabbits
were taken and the pig in the hedge hold
some hands of a badger what are you even
helping me what a dad does
Oh No Cottontail just discovered sugar
we have
[Music]
so what are you doing out here there is
a legend in the jungles of the Amazon of
a tree that heals or it could change the
world but if it gets into the wrong
hands
he could awaken a great evil
I believe that the legend is real dudes
man I'm gonna find out you all when I do
just imagine the lives that could be
saved I've been looking for this tree
longer than anybody I've tracked the
legend to every village every island
nothing to searching for something that
can't be found but you've never had the
key let's do something that's safe let's
go see some elephants they're all no
elephants in the Amazon and I don't even
like elephants lady everybody likes
elephants know this about the jungle
everything that you see wants to kill
you again
careful take it smell fear
oh my god
who brings a submarine to the Amazon oh
yeah
[Music]
get it come on I got it I don't got it
that was a disaster
go away
[Music]
what are you doing here in Somerville
anyway honestly my mom won't say it but
we're completely broke any on this thing
that's left in our name this is creepy
old farmhouse my grandfather left us in
the middle of nowhere why'd you bring me
up here entertainment value what is that
[Music]
somehow the town that isn't anywhere
near a tectonic plate that has no fault
lines no fracking no loud music even is
shaking on a daily basis
I remember that one summer we died under
a table I found this in my living room
chiller replica a replica of what a
ghost trap there hasn't been a ghost
sighting in 30 years New York in the 80s
it's like The Walking Dead your dad
never mentioned this to you it's just my
mom my grandfather died my mom says
we're just here to pick through the
rubble of his life
[Music]
who are you
[Music]
call it
[Music]
call it block
call it karma
I believe that everything happens for a
reason
come on darlin
it has a connor seat
[Music]
clothes organics six of our northern
cities have fallen in a coordinated
attack their leader fights alongside a
witch
crush these murderers Your Majesty every
family must contribute one man to fight
your war hero you've already made many
great sacrifices my father cannot fight
so I will take his place so no other new
fighters will kill her if I expose how
power all people will kill us when we
take the Imperial City I will take
revenge for my father
what is your name soldier
Wai ghin commander so no Poirot you will
now take the oath of the warrior
release
[Music]
by pretending to be something you're not
yet here I stand proof that there is a
place for people like us
a girl threatens our plans
a warrior
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm just not that good with people
there is one thing I'm good at
mission was to find out what they knew
but that's kind of difficult now that
you killed everyone
I just don't think you're cut out for
the intelligence this is your last shot
oh my god you have jelly all over your
face
I'm definitely posting that on insta is
it too late to home-school me are you
CIA Oh be streaming if Kim finds out we
got made by nine year old my career's
over what's the option kill her
make it look like an accident maybe the
stairs what Wow still recorded we can
cut a deal I want you to teach me how to
be a spy just to be clear this is a
one-time arrangement never again thank
you shooting range obstacle course try
to walk away from the explosion a lie
detector test I can smell a lie
endorphins really Shinoda and the
ultimate tell slightest blink of an eye
I admire all of your tattoos JJ I
believe he is that you've never taken
steroids damn she's good when you look
out there what do you see any civilians
minimal security software meter smiling
people having fun you should try it
sometime
[Music]
Mikey
[Applause]
the objective of this exercise was to
get past me a good idea might be to
cause the distraction because otherwise
there'd be zero chance of you
[Music]
what is he doing this looks like the
wedding at the end of Shrek we work for
the man oh no this isn't about the
Father this is about the son Artemis
Fowl
[Applause]
you've grown strong son and smarter than
I ever imagined don't take me with you I
have no RT it's just one very important
thing I have to do
[Music]
authorities launched a worldwide manhunt
for the famous collector he is suspected
to have been behind some of the biggest
robberies ever returned it to me or I
will destroy everything yes
anyone's supposed to see this yet
your father is in a complicated
profession for years
he is projected powerful secrets that
have kept mankind safe from the dangers
of another world it's time to face your
destiny but we are not alone in this
most items miss a talented giant Worf
and I'm Hollie short your ally on the
other side
it's real
alright save my father save the world
see ready telling we
let's get ahead onto this I'm scared to
death
[Applause]
see
on the next criminal mastermind
is what they call this I didn't breathe
much on trolls anything else to do cake
for Ricky hey people good to know shall
I tell your story
[Music]
it's story in the whole finger
he was sent to live in a serious house
if you cause me trouble have you sent
away with instance understand
but he discovered something
magical
something secret but let me start at the
beginning
my name is Mary Lennox my uncle owns
this house I'm Colin Craven and the
uncle you speaker is my father cousins
Tiny's your chair I've never been able
to move we could go outside who knows
you might feel better
who are you I'm digging I need to keep
secret to myself if you are too much of
a lady it is no I'm no lady son you know
the magical place taken extraordinary
things I'd say they were life do you
trust me
you know what you risk risk
Thank You kids on our side wait this
house just feel the light
laughter
puffiness
garden needs to kill :
there shouldn't kill him needs to his
house
[Music]
beautiful
[Music]